so Patrick welcome so Patrick is the
co-founder and CEO of stripe he launched
the startup we're now pretty big company
in 2010 correct with his brother John
why should we started working on it
full-time in 2010 but it actually your
comment just there about companies
launching it took us quite a while to
launch cuz we had all these kind of
banking partnerships in place and so on
and so we didn't launch until September
2011 and we've been working on it for
almost two years at that point and and
every time we saw PG or really anyone
else from YC all they would ask us is
why we did not launch some things don't
change that's interesting to two years
until you have to it was I think one
year and 11 months from sort of first
line of code to public launch which to
be clear I don't recommend that is not a
good idea it's just we had to because we
had to kind of get all these other
things in place and because it sort of
took us to so long to build a publicly
launched we're sort of we tried to be
kind of Airy disciplined about sort of
gradually expanding the number of users
every month and so even though we
weren't publicly available we got our
first user like first production user
just kind of three months in and then
have every month we tried to add at
least kind of a handful of users and so
by the time we publicly launched we did
have about a hundred users which I mean
back then to us you but that seemed like
a big deal that seemed very very large
speaking of actually when I was
preparing for this interview I I was
trying to talk my memories and I
remember specifically because your
office was near here in Palo Alto and I
remember back then people would always
talk about the call us and brothers
running around going to people's offices
and like installing their API into the
web apps and you know in true do things
don't scale fashion and I assume you are
not only trying to make sure they
installed it but also get user feedback
and it happened so much that actually I
don't know if you know program PG now
calls it the Cullison installation
and this is actually something we give
and we tell founders to go do this
do the call us and installation because
obviously you know it in hindsight it
seems so obvious to do well it sort of
served two purposes and one is to your
point
I mean it's art it's a really good way
to kind of get sort of user research and
to get kind of UX feedback and so on and
I mean if you've done this I'm sure you
had the experience for you design which
are absolutely certain is the most
streamlined user-friendly
straightforward frictionless way to you
know do whatever it is the product does
and then you kind of you you you you
present it and kind of put it in front
of a user and you just kind of ask them
to do whatever it is and you know they
find it completely impenetrable and like
they're clicking all the wrong links and
they can't find the next button even
though the next button is they're
blinking and green and stuff and so it's
invariably so incredibly painful at the
sort of nothing so sobering as watching
somebody use kind of that the first
version of of you know some new product
but the other reason for us was you know
we would suggest to somebody they use
stripe or they switch to stripe whatever
and you know invariably the responses
oh yeah sure that sounds awesome and but
you know it can be postponed and locals
phone it again and just like there's
never a moment or it's like okay this is
the evening or I'm going to switch to
stripe and so us going and sort of
accosting them in person sort of helped
you know great you know if you'll talk
code in sales it's almost like a you
know of why you and I why this and why
now and these kinds of questions and and
going in person could have created a why
now moment it's like what we're here at
your house did you just show up or how
did you I don't think we ever actually
showed up and although perhaps we should
have but um you know we we we try to to
be kind of at least semi invited so so
stripe now today I mean you've come a
long way since back then I mean it's not
even it's really been a decade not even
but I mean today you're what you have
1,300 employees across nine offices
across the world you're doing I have a
list here you manage 200 million API
requests a day you process billions a
year for millions of companies across
hundred 30 companies new latest round of
funding stripe is now worth 20 million
dollars
billion anyway let's go going on I'm not
gonna stop they're all there otherwise
people think I'm your PR agent
but anyway you've clearly done something
right
and so I want to spend a lot of I guess
the time today talking about running
your startup from the perspective of the
start-up CEO you yourself and it's kind
of like zoom like what do you think
about from zooming in and the day-to-day
operations to zooming out to the
long-term strategic decisions so maybe
to help us ease into the discussion one
thing is you know when you start off you
know one from the very beginning a lot
of friends get together and they come
for the idea and they're super excited
and they start working on it and then at
some point they need to decide we need
to see you for this company and some
people you know aren't meant to be CEOs
but for you and John you know I've met
both of you you're very smart ambitious
people with great you know qualities
that end attributes that correlate to
becoming great leader how did you and
John decide you would be the CEO well I
think stripe is unusual for you know
John my RFC brothers and we've known
each other for a long time and and and
you know because of the relationship we
real sort of place a lot of trust in
each other and and we really do run the
company together and there's no major
decision that sort of stripe has made
that sort of that we've not both been a
part of and and you know it's not always
the case that you know despite being the
CEO that kind of I'm the person who like
in the case of disagreement it's not all
it's not all the case that I prevail
instead of our kind of dispute
resolution framework it's kind of much
more around which of us carries more
than kind of which most holds this title
earth and I mean John's title as
president and so it was kind of some
both are significant roles and so I'm
yeah in that regard I think we're kind
of an anomaly he said of the fact that I
became CEO was honestly semi-random
and
and I would say yeah I think because
we're brothers being able to kind of get
to this unusual situation where we
really do run it together is there a
certain would you sorry may not be a
helpful answer because perhaps you're
trying to encourage all these companies
it's like you know [ __ ] what do you got
guys has got to be the the CEO but do
you think there's like a rubric for this
of you know here are five questions you
should answer maybe then you decide
that's good question um-hmm you know
yeah I'm guessing it's quite okay well I
wasn't one thing which is I think it is
important just have an efficient
mechanism for reaching a decision and it
can't be sort of you know simply orange
around consensus right if there's sort
of three co-founders and sort of none of
you sort of quite want to or you know
nobody's a clear CEO and you don't have
some kind of efficient mechanism first
that of having decisions get made I
think that is a recipe for failure and
and even I don't know doing some kind of
you know sort of quasi democratic voting
is probably not a great idea either and
so so for myself and John we kind of
both have areas we kind of respected we
specialize in and so that doesn't mean
we kind of have absolute ultimate
authority there but so do we be kind of
biased in that direction so he spends
more time for example of working
externally with users I spend more of my
time working to have internally unloved
you know product and engineering things
that nothing to say that he doesn't make
decisions there or I don't here but
again there's a bias in that direction
and then second we have this kind of
additional aspect where you know in case
of a being a major decision and we
should respectively disagree then then
we really do sort of try to make it
based on sort of which of us is kind of
is just more passionate about it and
because that that will correlate with
the outcome one of us really wants to do
something or think that you know X or Y
is the right thing to do simply sort of
wanting is to be so passionately is more
I mean that can become a sort of
self-fulfilling prophecy and so I think
it's kind of not irrational to have that
be a consideration yeah I also see like
the best teams that work well together
are the ones in which everyone they they
all want the best idea to win not their
idea to win
and so there's a stepping back and an
unselfish kind of way to to get to that
conclusion definitely and I think that
you know something that working on lucky
about that I think is very well exactly
to your point I think he's definitely
present in sort of the most successful
co-founding relationships that I've seen
is some degree of sort of dispassion in
disagreement and you know for us I think
that was you know kind of easier to get
to because you know we've been
disagreeing with each other for 20 years
and so it had lost some of the emotional
charge but I think that sort of finding
other mechanisms whereby you can get
there such that it's not sort of this I
don't know that this kind of but the
notion of disagreeing strongly is not
sort of a scary phenomena and that kind
of both parties or multiple parties if
they're more than two are kind of
suppressing their feelings for fear of
of there being this divergence you've
how many more siblings do you have via
one more brother
one more sibling yes okay three three of
us in total would you guys would he join
the or is it just you and John are the
special match there well the Tommy my
youngest sibling he's sort of quite a
bit younger than myself and John and so
um you know John is almost approximately
two years younger than I am and you know
when we started stripe I guess I was
about 21 and I think I guess therefore
John was 19 and and Tommy was still kind
of definitively midway through high
school and so it wasn't quite practical
at the time yes finished high school and
now I think you know if you asked him he
probably said he'd never throw his lot
in with you know miscreants like us yeah
cool so in terms of the role is to you
often people say there there's a there's
a threshold in time in which and it's
related to product market fit where that
you have a role as a pre product market
fit to you and then which is completely
different from your role as a post
product market fit to you so I want to
spend most of our time talking about pre
product market fit but just to calibrate
those questions what in terms for stripe
what was product market fit for you like
how did you define it or their metrics
to it
number of employees you are at when you
reached it so forth yeah that's a really
good question and I think you're exactly
right to kind of divide things into sort
of there's kind of the story of a
start-up is two stories and it's a story
of getting to product market fit and
then the story of kind of what happens
subsequently and obviously there isn't
like a totally definitive binary line
between them but I think it's kind of
helpful to frame the narrative in that
regard and I would see for stripe and
actually around the time we launched
publicly I think is is basically when we
had it and that we when we launched
publicly in September 2011 you know we
can rebuild significant components of
stripe kind of multiple times in
response to user feedback like we're
kind of on the third version of our
dashboard and the second or third hand
how you count major version of our API
and so we'd kind of gone through a lot
of iteration response to kind of the you
know evident challenges that these are
hat users had or the deficiencies the
product seemed to possess and and when
we launched we were basically
immediately bottlenecked on sort of
being able to serve user demand rather
than generating user demand and I think
sort of directionally that's kind of the
the sort of the inversion that happens
first it is you know in the early days
you should have really trying to figure
out well okay kind of you know
conditioned on or given some user how do
I make sure that it's if it does what
they need and you know they end up a
happy retained user in a you know a
sufficient fraction of cases or whatever
and then kind of at some point it flows
for okay the sort of well you know I I
think it's kind of very different do you
sort of take you know a hundred users
and you know some fraction of them on
board and some smaller fraction you know
remain engaged or whatever and so kind
of 100 users the curve sort of a sort of
asymptotes downwards and then you take
100 users and kind of again a meaningful
fraction end up engage and they actually
tell more people about it or they sort
of invite people I don't even have
strictly just in a viral sense but it's
kind of generally speaking just that
kind of lead to and generate more demand
such a thing soon to be sort of a sort
of in some super linear fashion kind of
growing and I think when you sort of
like being kind of less than one is just
very different to being more than one
and it sort of seems again when we
launched I mean that didn't generate
that many users I mean I don't think I
could remember but let's just pretend
that sort of 500 businesses signed up on
the day we launched butts of immediately
those 500 businesses told other
businesses and people heard about it all
the rest so kind of the next day we had
a lot of businesses as well and and so
forth
such that from the day we launched the
challenge became keeping up with demand
rather than tweaking the product to
somehow serve the market when you
watched how many people were you at at
that point employees we're about 10 so I
guess before you launch then but your
day to day sounds like it was just like
we were talking about earlier just
running around talking with users and
fixing issues what was that literally
every single day was like that or what
were you doing everything okay so not
literally every single day but I would
say and we really tried very hard to
understand into the very granular detail
what exactly it was that people were
doing you know where they were tripping
up and so on it's just to give you some
examples we had a chat room for sort of
providing support when people were
integrating stripe and it was it was
actually a public chat room which kind
of had some downsides because you know
if we'd broken something or if somebody
had some kind of embarrassing issues
sort of everyone would see it but we
thought that was kind of good because it
would actually can put more pressure on
us to sort of have the product to be
good and we had literally every time a
sort of for the first I don't know
called 10 years of stripe
every time somebody sent an API requests
to stripe like it sent an email to us so
we were like looking at every single API
request and you know if we saw users do
something weird why did they do that
right or kind of where were our Doc's
confusing or whatever and say you know I
get a dinner in the evening or something
and I've but you know well again it
seems like a lot that I might've you
know maybe 10 email list because stripe
was not handling a lot of API requests
back then but but sort of you're
literally looking at sort of each
individual action and actually stripe
and we just kind of celibate celebrated
or at least pass I'm very good at
celebrating but we passed our seventh
anniversary just you know a few days ago
on September 29th
and so I was looking at our sort of we
had an hourly stats email that we used
to send and and so on the day we
launched we handled sort of 22 payments
in the previous hour which again sort of
seemed huge to us back then but I was
noticing in that email I actually
forgotten this that we had things like m
in the in the email we literally had a
list of businesses that had submitted
three or five or something API requests
but it's sort of not gonna if they did
not launch their businesses wheeler just
had the emails of all these businesses
the idea was that we would then kind of
we literally individually reach out to
them it's like hey you can have seemed
you strive a little bit but you know you
didn't I didn't go live like did we
screw up or you know was the product
somehow inadequate or whatever we did
things like every time anyone ever hit
an error of any sort that generated like
a high priority email to us and so it
sort of try to immediately go Salvage
and that also kind of generated sort of
I think this M this Pleasant kind of
user experience for I mean you know it's
frustrating when you hit an error in
some service but we could then often
sort of 15 minutes later reach out to
them and say hey we saw the tubes have
been counted the problem it's it's all
fixed now and sometimes we did even in
the case were sort of them the users
made a silly mistake and that you know
they'd be kind of mistyped an API
parameter or something and we just reach
out to them they're like hey noticed you
had a typo in your code which you know
perhaps and some of them is a little bit
unsettling but but but at least gonna
helped us you know increase the kind of
the throughput of product feedback but
so I mean these are all kind of examples
I would say of the sort of general
pattern of sort of really trying to be
kind of hyper attentive to all the micro
details of sort of what people were
doing the product and kind of iterating
rapidly in response to it and generally
speaking I think that sort of pre
product market fit metrics are actually
relatively unhelpful and I think you
should have you really want to buy us
very strongly towards kind of as much
sort of inspection and kind of high
throughput qualitative feedback as
possible because probably no not that
many people are using your product right
and so you know if it's 20 users you can
kind of in some sense afford to just
like look at everything they're doing
and try to understand kind of you know
what's working what isn't in some sense
it's how much do they you can tell
actively like how much they love your
product how much are they gonna probably
be really upset if it just disappears
totally and actually on this point we
had a thing at the bottom of every
webpage we had a little sort of text box
and kind of Anchorage to the bottom of
the of the sort of thumb of the browser
frame and and sort of a you know kind of
one line high sort of text input and but
we had placeholder text in it I had to
sort of try to prying people to tell us
things and so it had you know my my
favorite part of stripe is ellipsis and
you know people just fill it out I'm
gonna hit enter now but we also of
course had you know MOOC most of the
problems were negative it was you know
like the worst thing about stripe is or
the worst thing that this page is or I
really hate the way stripe does or
whatever and and again we would sort of
sort of at that stage you have to be
kind of masochistic and so again we'd be
sort of always waking up to you know all
these emails you know telling us all the
terrible things about stripe but that it
was you know if I helpful to-do list for
the day ahead how did you stay happy if
look in the early days I mean for every
story complaints what makes you think we
did so it was it was what happy is such
a squishy concept right and because like
there are lots of things that we are I
guess when I look back and look maybe
this is the rationalization I taught
myself but when I look back and sort of
through life other things that I'm sort
of most glad I did I wasn't exactly
happy well doing them like often I was
very stressed out or you know I had to
work really hard or whatever but to the
things that kind of post hoc brought the
most fulfillment and and you know I
think that well you know part of it
there's a rich literature here and so I
won't kind of died too deeply into it
but I do think kind of happiness is a is
a tricky concept to kind of pin down
because you know is that kind of
happiness in the moment is it sort of
the sense that you have a year later
looking back and so on and so I think
and you know language is squishy and
it's not you know completely
specifically defined but I think kind of
generally speaking kind of a better
utility function and kind of gradient
reddit line is that of fulfillment and
and so I would take an experience of
doing stripe was it was not especially
happy because we were sort of you know
constantly sort of incredibly aware of
all the ways in which the product was
severely deficient and you know all the
challenges we faced and I mean it seemed
like there was no FinTech category back
then it was just like two teenagers or
you know just just over teenagers trying
to compete with PayPal which you know
many people told us was not an
especially kind of promising Avenue to
pursue and so not especially happy per
se and but it did feel kind of
fulfilling and like I enjoyed working
with John and the kind of people were
separately hired and it was really fun
working with the kinds of kind of
customers we were serving and they're
just sort of businesses doing all these
kind of wonderful things and they were
kind of really smart people and it felt
that like if it worked it could be kind
of consequential in the world and so I
would say kind of it's it's sort of felt
like I mean well you know I don't know
what it feels like to be sort of a
scientist or something but I'm guessing
when you're sort of pursuing all you
have this kind of big question and
you're appreciating all these kind of
haven't used to sort of try to better
understand - and I'm guessing day to day
it's sort of not especially happy
because most your experiments don't work
or whatever but sort of in for perhaps
there's some analogue there in terms of
them it still feels like it was in some
sense meaningful yeah they're in some
sense I mean it did add a like you said
you just you're running around with your
head cut off but maybe on a weekly or at
least monthly basis is just taking a
step back and seeing like what progress
have I actually made because week to
week it's like one percent here one
percent here it doesn't seem much but
from a monthly basis or you know maybe
longer than that it it seems like
there's movement
ya know I think that's true and I think
III don't know like I think it's almost
took me a bad idea to sort of work on a
company or to work on anything if if
you're like truly unhappy working right
and so there's kind of charities and
balancing act there
and I think I mean a lot of well they're
sort of so many differences of them
difficult judgement calls to try to make
in a start-up but you know of course
part of it is like if something is
making you unhappy or if it just doesn't
seem like an especially promising Avenue
or it's not really working whatever like
your time has relatively high
opportunity costs like you don't get to
start that many startups in your life
right and so kind of knowing when to
sort of call it quits I think it is
actually I mean sort of you know in
start-up them we really extol and serve
uphold the virtues of sort of you know
determination at all costs you know
never quit and so on and you know that's
clearly not the right answer and that's
like sometimes you should quit and so um
so I think how much of getting it is
true and right for I think that does
need to be some sort of some happiness
satisfaction fulfillment this good book
of that of that name satisfaction which
I recommend kind of week to week month
to month if you're on the right
trajectory oh man I wish I'd known that
I could have you know what I remember
when I was trying to when I was about to
put stripe myself I had these bad
memories of trying to implement PayPal
and like stacks the documentation and
taking like five days to figure it all
out and so I sat down I was like it's
because you guys are saying oh it took
you ten minutes it's like no way and it
probably took me actually five minutes
at that point and I was I was super
happy I mean that's like but maybe I
should have sent you a review yeah
especially if the review noted sort of
criticism for us but no it's definitely
helpful to have competitors with not
very good products yes okay so you were
in the early days you were doing a lot
of stuff yourself at some point I guess
too two-part question one is one of the
things that you weren't good at and then
too at what point did you hire someone
to what what I assume is to do those
things well I mean I'm I'm not that good
at most things right and I say there's a
non sort of false modesty or
I don't mean artificially
self-deprecating but said for almost
anything that stripe has to do those are
the people who were better at that than
I am and so I think to some degree sort
of the story of say you know product
market fit and to you know say our
current stage is kind of implementing
the recognition of that in kind of more
and more areas that said I think maybe
sort of embedded in that question is you
know okay well acknowledging that you're
playing out the world's expert in in any
single thing it's kind of in what order
do you sort of replace yourself and for
stripe the sort of the the important
thing they were sort of most obviously
not that great at was kind of
partnerships and you know working with
the various banks that we had to sort of
get on board and and so on and so kind
of we made them in fact Geoff Ralston
who is here in the room today I think
sort of was you know some combination of
sort of very supportive and perhaps in
the back of his minds of slightly
pitying you know where he saw us kind of
trying to get these partnerships with
these kind of big banks in place and we
really weren't sort of getting and they
were very fast and so he told us that we
had to hire this guy Billy Alvarado and
I told us just don't ask me questions
just hire this guy and at the time
everyone everyone at stripe was an
engineer and so we just we couldn't
quite understand what a non engineer
would do like you're not earning code
what I was you know is there and and so
we were kind of suspicious of this idea
and and we sort of we went back to Jeff
we met Billy he seems like a wonderful
guy we really liked him but we couldn't
quite get past this okay but like what
does it actually how does this work out
in practice and so Jeff told us that we
should hire Billy and it didn't work it
over the first few months or whatever
that if it didn't work out Jeff would go
back and pay his salary so it's kind of
a zero risk move for us and and so and
we didn't have a whole lot of money at
the time so that was not insignificant
so we
we heard Billy and that was sort of an
immediately trajectory changing event
for you no previous leaving me gone and
talked to a bank I mean I know they're
literally doing this but it certainly
felt they were kind of pushing the
security button under their desk it's
like what are these guys in my office
and and then suddenly things start to go
kind of much more smoothly and and Billy
is still with stripe today and day has
been an enormous ly kind of the pivotal
presence and so that was um
turned out to be very helpful advice
that is interesting just as an
inflection point for stripe never new
cool so it sounds like you had hired
actually people before Billy I guess
first your very first hire the third
person between with you and John it was
an engineer I'm assuming like well he
actually wasn't an engineer but he
joined stripe and he started to become
an engineer so like he'd written a
little bit of code previously but he
joined a lot of codes I had to written
it was a guy I'd known from college he's
actually also Irish and yeah we love
code to be written and so he was the
kind of person who you know would sort
of survey that landscape and just do
whatever it was was you know most
important and required and at that time
I was writing code and so he went so
kind of the transition from pre pardon
mark fit to post product market fit I
want to see use when they think back
this is like the one point in which they
think I could have done that better so
how do you how do you create your
success of that transition because a lot
of it is you know just taking stuff
delegating stuff better and doing other
functions of the business so what
exactly was your transition like and you
know how would you how could I if I was
going in your shoes tell that I was
doing it well yes I I don't think I did
it especially well and I think it kind
of you know fortunately sort of you know
it worked out but I think if if I was
doing it all over again I think we could
have sort of accelerated ourselves by a
year or two if we'd sort of gone about
it in a somewhat more disciplined and
kind of self-aware fashion I think the I
think one of those kind of pernicious
a sort of mental models you can have
here is the kind of you are on some
growth curve and it is sort of your job
to sustain or you know marginally
inflect upwards or kind of somehow and
you know that much of them is curling
the sport where you're kind of you know
wiping the ice while the overt is the
weight a precedes down along it sorry
I'm not Canadian but um and but kind of
somehow you're kind of making kind of
these very small interventions and
perturbations on some underlying growth
curve and I think that's an easy mental
model to have and I think it's kind of
you know actively kind of fallacious and
mistaken I think I have a much better
mental model to have is you're serving
some market and that market is I mean
for its relatively finite in size I mean
you can always you know change the
project and increase the market size but
sort of you know you can you can think
of it as being finite and then there's
sort of the percentage of the market
that you're serving and then you know
whatever percentage you are not serving
is kind of well you just haven't built
the sort of go to market functions and
organization that's kind of capable or
at least has yet sort of brought the
product to those market segments and the
kind of the growth curve or adoption
curve is just kind of a function of of
that go to market apparatus but
basically it's it's it's not some kind
of cosmic trajectory it's something kind
of very much of your creation and under
your control and so what I what we did
not do but what I wish we did is kind of
maybe whatever you know just after we
launch me there's a whole bunch of kind
of immediate scaling work we have to do
but say six months after launch that we
should have sort of mapped out the kind
of concentric circles of our market like
maybe there's kind of you know very
early-stage startups there were kind of
a you know our sort of initial initial
constituency then there's kind of all
technical startups but not necessarily
very early stage and it's kind of I
don't know you you you keep going these
kind of successive increments until
eventually got to say all companies
handling online payments or something
right and I'm gonna sort of figure it
out okay kind of what's the size of this
market sort of you know kind of what
fraction of are we currently serving
what would it take to serve more and so
on and I think it's quite striking you
see that kind of when and repeat
founders going
start companies they almost invariably
are willing to kind of build the
organization you know post prime market
it so it's invariably willing to kind of
build the organization ahead of where
things are today and which I think is
exactly the right thing to do because
they're thinking okay I have the right
product now that's gonna work backwards
from okay what would the organization
looked like that was serving the entire
market and let's just start building
that organization because again the
growth curve is under my control
and you know of course it's not like
100% under your control but I think it's
much more under your control than then
things that people don't think there's
also of course a difference here a major
difference when you can use or I think
about sort of consumer versus kind of
b2b use cases where consumer it's a bit
more I mean people don't necessarily
know exactly what they want you know
what's the the market size for like a
news reading app or a dating app or
something I mean it's it's a kind of it
depends a lot on the product like you
know maybe when more people should be
reading news or something but for fer
sort of a for some service or a product
that sort of serves a discrete logical
concrete function that sort of set of
businesses or entities to finish early
have or don't have I think it's kind of
much more sort of much more rational and
much more mapable and I partly had this
epiphany Vienna Aaron Levie who's the
CEO of Box John I eventually we started
an Palo Alto we moved up to San
Francisco I don't well Aaron Levie um
had Facebook message on and and we've
never heard of him and heard of most
people in Silicon Valley and but he'd
Facebook messaged us like very early on
asking to invest in stripe and I think
John didn't know this is a random guy
and so we never replied and but then you
know we heard of Fox and we heard of
Aaron and you know we've read his funny
tweets and all the rest and so we moved
to San Francisco and and we invited him
to our housewarming I think was the
first time we'd ever met him and sort of
you know like we're not very good at
partying and so you know by a sort of
11:00 p.m. or you know midnight or
something kind of everyone was going
home and but Aaron was still there and
an Aaron state owns like 2:00 a.m. I
still remember kind of sitting in our
front room telling us how much better at
woz be building b2b software than
consumer software for this reason our
sort of consumer
for it's so hard to predict sort of what
people want they don't even know
themselves what they want you're kind of
you're it's such an amorphous space
whereas when you're selling software to
businesses you know businesses are kind
of are mostly rational are mostly the
opposite of inscrutable is scrutiny I
guess and and you can sort of work
backwards in a way that sort of it's
just much more comprehensible and so um
I still have this kind of you know it's
like the angel and demon on your
shoulder I still have sort of you know -
am Aaron Levie sitting on my shoulders
of extolling the virtues of building
software for entities that know what
they want you've made the right choice
yeah in some senses there's a lot less
variables or in consumer there's a lot
more variables to to consider and
they're quite unknown I want to take a
step back and you talked a little bit
about you know thinking about thinking
ahead about what your team is or what
your company structure is going to look
like how do you maybe this is too big of
a question so I mean we can whittle it
down a little bit but how do you think
about that like like I'm sitting if I'm
starting a start-up today I am close to
maybe a product market fit but before
that stage like am I thinking about this
sort of thing i watch my team look like
what should my culture be and stuff like
that I think that then well okay so pre
prime market fit um I mean the goal is
really is just to gas to product market
fish and so I actually wouldn't bother
thinking too much but all these kind of
distribution mechanics questions now you
can get probably a good fit sort of
relatively quickly and so kind of that
pre-primary at this stage might only
last six months you know you're not
necessarily like stripe or you're gonna
in it for various reasons for first of
multiple years and so it may not last
very long however until that point I
really think you should just be think
about okay how do I get there the main
thing that I think companies screw up at
that prepartum are could fit the sage
and is sort of speed of iteration I
think okay well what determines or you
kind of speed of fruitful iteration and
and that sort of I mean if you're kind
of completely or if you're repeatedly
rebuilding our product but sort of
national response user feedback I mean
that's that's kind of far less likely to
be kind of bringing you in sort of a in
a productive direction but if you have
some kind of meaning
albeit perhaps smalls of initial set of
users and your rapidly iterating in
response to sort of their feedback and
sort of observed behavior and so on then
I think that's like a really good spot
to be in and I think again at that
juncture a pre prod market fish it is
kind of this you should be sort of doing
everything you can to tighten that sort
of feedback cycle and there's a fighter
pilot in who kind of revolutionized
airborne combat in the US and said of
the second half the 20th century so
Korean War onwards and called boid and
he had this concept of the OODA loop
which was sort of a sort of a similar
notion I was the most improve you see
people thought you want to just like the
fastest aircraft or said that you know
most sophisticated weaponry and so on
where he was all about sort of no you
actually want an aircraft that instead
of pilots and training that are really
oriented around sort of the fastest sort
of responsiveness in iteration to the
cut particulars of the situation in a
way that kind of subsequently went on to
really inform sort of modern aircraft
design and so I think you want to be
like and one of these sort of these
modern fighters every year sort of
really optimized to respond as quickly
as possible to sort of rapidly evolving
situations again and it's kind of
pre-primed market at stage and so then
from a hiring standpoint I think I think
it should really be about okay well
what's gonna sort of what's going to get
you there faster and I mean I think it
an early stage it's most likely well
sort of just people who help you kind of
build the product but of course not too
many because I mean at some point like
not be able to do more but you might
actually be less responsive because
you're bigger team to manage or
something right and so as an empirical
matter it seems that somewhere between
kind of you know two and ten depending
on exactly what you're building is kind
of the optimally responsive size but but
I think it really is about that sort of
him time from observed sort of necessity
or deficiency or just you know
characteristic of your users behavior to
executed fix or improvement and whatever
it is that kind eyes is that is there I
mean you say two to ten which is helpful
but is there are there observations or
evidence in which you have hit the peak
like you should not add an X like this
extra person is going to be negative
value add to the whole operation yeah I
mean every person every person well
startups in general involve all these
kind of impossibly difficult of judgment
calls in this kind of you know high
dimensional possibility space and so it
would be great if you could sort of
collapse it down to kind of a fairly
simple set of trade-offs that is I don't
think you can however I think in
principle the calculations that are
trying to run is ok and each successive
person takes time to hire and so slows
us down in that regard takes time to
unmoor slows that in that regard kind it
takes time to understand meld with the
sort of culture and learn the stack on
the stuff that that also takes constant
time then involves subsequent ongoing
cost of just like coordination and
alignment and sort of you know you you
should now have you know the
organizations that distributed across
more neurons and and so there's that
kind of persistent tax and that's not
just necessarily a linear cost but it
you know it can be sort of you know
quadratic or something kind of given you
know the multi way communication problem
so you of all these costs to an
additional person so the question is
okay but this person can also help us
with like get more [ __ ] done right they
can write more code or talk to Moe users
or whatever and so it's kind of is that
fixed benefit to sort of that additional
person worth all these other costs and
again with I think the ultimate arbiter
being will we be more responsive to what
we're learning about our users given the
presence of this additional person and I
think you know whether or not you will
be dependent the complexity the product
and the complexity of the market and you
know all that stuff but but I think
that's in principle the calculation you
might be running I've heard you said and
speaking of hiring people I've heard you
said you know the key qualities that you
look for in a future stripe employee is
intellectually honest cares a great deal
and just loves getting things done which
are great attributes because some people
just don't fit in those categories so
it's good to have that separation there
how do you when you meet someone how do
you figure out this is the right person
it's very hard and and I wish I had a
more sort of a sort of definitive rubric
and kind of particular set of questions
although if I had a particular set of
questions maybe you know they'd you know
they'd stop working because kind of
would learn how to how to game them or
something and so I mean it well it's
hard to fake just being smart right
and so that one's kind of not as hard to
discern and and I it's oddly hard to
fake being intellectually honest and and
so the characters who kind of being able
to see multiple sides of a debate or an
argument like there are so many kind of
complicated questions for so the only
thing that I'm really skeptical of is
kind of certainty in either direction
just because you know the questions are
intrinsically sort of involve very
contingent trade-offs it's also it's not
impossible but it's hard ish to fake
just being nice and like something
something we care a lot about it's
stripe is is just sort of people who are
pleasant and warm and sort of just you
know make it others happier as a result
of their presence and you know if well
you know perhaps if you can fake that
perfectly forever you know that's fine
right but but yeah they're all and sort
of actually there's no clear rubric for
them and I'm not sure that the peer
rubric could even work yeah so you talk
about like get people who help move the
organization faster if at all possible
and I think there are two issues usually
that start slowing down the organization
as you start scaling just cuz each
person adds just more complexity than
organization but also I think one is
asymmetric information just people don't
want that guard never on the same page
and I think you've talked a lot about
this I think and there so everyone can
google around for lectures you've given
on this on you've done email
transparency you know obviously you know
having metrics transparent to the home
ization but the second problem to that
is if you fix that there's also this
asymmetric interpretation problem which
is everyone's there's just like black
box function that how people interpret
eight even if all the inputs are
the same the outputs are all different
and it's official at your skill now it's
nearly impossible to figure out
everybody's function so when you're
thinking about creating your
organization and building it out like
how do you reduce that reduce that noise
and and try to get everyone on the same
page yeah and well the first thing is I
wish we had actually between say five
and fifty people and I think we were
much too
consensus oriented we of course weren't
completely consensus oriented I mean we
couldn't have gotten anything done if we
were but I think we kind of biased too
much in that direction and again I've
seen a it's just not that efficient
right and it's sort of it's it's
necessarily not the case and so kind of
you like you can sort of perhaps
maintain some kind of fiction for you
know more or less time but but sort of
ultimately speaking the third there is
no way of sort of sustaining that and I
think that's a relatively common mistake
right and because you know you almost
invariably come from so some kind of you
know n Musketeers for so small and sort
of kind of orientation whereas it is
there's no particular need for sort of
formal decision-making mechanisms or
sort of you know subsequent
communication of said decisions or
whatever right but then you can hit
fifteen people and now there is and come
I think companies don't adjust quickly
enough to sort of that new necessity
again very much as included and so I
actually think we did relatively well on
the kind of ambient availability of sort
of context and information so on but
actually kind of in some sense poorly at
sort of deliberate explicit
communication of of decisions decisions
being I mean actual kind of tactical
decisions or even you know bigger
decisions like you know what are our
priorities the next six months or things
of that nature and so the higher order
piece of advice and perhaps I'm over
extrapolating from our personal
experience but Hydra advice just kind of
reflecting back would be to kind of it's
kind of like the pre and post pop
probably market fit thing it's sort it's
actually about the size of the
organization we're kind of when you hit
a certain size again maybe I'm just
gonna say ten people for the sake of
simplicity a bit before it's a bit after
I think you to kind of adjust more more
deliberately to this kind of explicitly
eunuch ation model of sort of of being
sort of quite quite firmly non consensus
based and and sort of I mean nobody
nobody likes the idea of sort of being
hierarchical that sounds pejorative but
like in some sense hierarchical sort of
the top-down like it does move things
faster maybe some people don't like that
yes it does that's right that's right
and there is this can delicate balancing
act you you want to sort of orchestrate
we're kind of on the one hand you want
to sort of really prioritize speed and
agility which involves being kind of
somewhat a hierarchical because those
are sort of efficient sort of symmetry
breaking mechanisms and ways to sort of
have shots get called but on the other
side you really do want people to have
this kind of strong ownership mentality
and and real sense that sort of they
they can cause think things to change or
identify problems or sort of inject new
ideas even in unrelated areas and so
it's this a delicate act where I mean
you definitely can be excessively
hierarchical but sort of how do you sort
of facilitate enough autonomy and agency
them but also not have things devolve
into this kind of I don't know sort of a
uniform morass of sort of all these kind
of of a Brownian motion and and and I
think that's hard and requires all these
kind of you know ongoing sort of tweaks
and nudges and I mean is dependent on
the personalities involved and all the
rest and again I you know I really wish
there was kind of the sort of wrote
simple I'll just do XY and Z and you'll
be good but sort of if such XY z-- and
Z's exist you know no one's told me yet
if only there was a formula for
everything so riding on the same theme
you know as stripe grows you strike me
as a company that does the opposite of
most companies which was they get bigger
they just slow down and they get less
innovative but for you guys and it's
hard to even keep up like you're just
pumping out new products and which seem
to be successful to me like stripe Atlas
try press stripe terminal so and so
forth so in the
early days you know when there's just 9
or 10 of you if someone had a new idea
it's probably really easy to get to you
and you know then you guys would decide
how has that changed over time to make
sure that someone who's like six level
six degrees away from you that a good
idea actually gets to you and then how
does that decision made to actually
execute on upon it um well I'm it's very
nice to you say that I feel that we're
getting faster as we get bigger because
you know we're constantly sort of
self-flagellating over how like freaking
slow we are and like paranoid about sort
of I don't know degenerating into some
kind of you know sort of immobile stupor
and so to whatever extent we do get
things done or or appear fast I think
it's largely because we we're very
paranoid in this dimension and and I
think that kind of the the default
outcome of companies of course as they
scale is to become sort of more ossified
and rigid and sort of closed to new
ideas and directions and things that
contradict their prevailing orthodoxies
and all of that as how we kind of avoid
that and I mean well there's lots of
kind of obvious things like partly it's
it's sort of I mean having leaders who
care about the rate of progress and and
just love seeing things happen quickly
and lots of things of that nature
and I think maybe sort of deeper rooted
as we try to be a kind of yes and
culture in that I mean I personally love
just ideas and potential things we could
do and I mean most of them are or I mean
no matter how good the idea is sort of
we should not pursue most ideas right
even if independently it could be a
super successful comfort or something
but like there is a fairly finite number
of things we can do and so sort of you
kind of on the one hand need to
recognize that intellectually and just
like not pursue most things while on the
other hand enjoying the exercise of
contemplating well what it looked like
if we did it right and so you know one
thing we do every year for example is we
have this kind
crazy ideas process.we college where we
literally sent a document to the whole
company a hackpad document that that's
open to everyone and people can sort of
add ideas to it that they think are
probably a bad idea but if they worked
might be a great idea
and it's very important that they have
to be probably a bad idea because if
they're like probably a good idea then I
mean it's not that risky and I mean kind
of by definition we should ply do it and
so we know whatever it may be just do it
and so people like really self-censor a
lot in most organizations because they
don't look stupid and they don't be sort
of associated with just having all these
like wacky bad ideas and so on and so we
try to be fairly firm that if you add
ideas it has to be probably a bad idea
and and actually a lot of cool things
we've subsequently got on and done the
first came from the process it's try
Pappas you know being one of them
and and also we we sort of helped
stellar it could off the ground this
sort of cryptocurrency back a few years
ago instead of that also sort of came
from this process and so that's one of
the mechanisms by which we try to have a
kind of yes and culture and I really
think there aren't that many as just as
an empirical matter and there aren't
that many large organizations that I
think sort of really do this
successfully but I think that sort of
the the most successful of larger
organizations somehow do succeed and
sort of this iterative repeated repeated
process of kind of augmentation
you know Amazon and Google being have
the most prominent examples for you know
obviously even Google launched there was
no Gmail or YouTube or Android or Google
Maps or whatever and you know Amazon
sort of is kind of an even more
conspicuous example in some sense this
kind of repeated attach of successful
ancillary businesses and so I think kind
of yeah there's a very natural
temptation as you grow to I think become
increasingly close to this I think is
very important to avoid cool so I have a
couple more questions and then maybe
we'll have time to take questions from
the audience one is are looking back
is there something did you have a strong
opinion of you know how startups should
be run as a CEO that have just
completely reversed because you're now
to see you it's a good question and
another way to potentially put it is
like what are what are things that you
did were you're like I know for sure
this should have been done and they just
turned out to be a mistake well I
already mentioned the set of the
consensus orientation when they were
going through right now which is a quite
sort of significant divergence is a you
know we were sort of fairly centralized
and up until sort of relative recently I
mean we had some remote employees from
pretty early stage but so by and large
stripe was kind of concentrated in San
Francisco a.m. last week we announced
our fourth global hub and basically
we've decided to do is we're going to
have kind of major sort of product and
engineering sort of efforts and teams
and functions and all the rest in San
Francisco also in Seattle also in Dublin
and also in Singapore and and sort of
these nonsensical locations they're not
gonna be sort of I know operations
offices or satellite offices or you know
places where we do have some
localization and local market adaptation
we want to have kind of completely de
novo new products that sort of become
super successful started out of these
offices and that's not the sort of
standard obviously kind of Silicon
Valley pattern and we're sort of Apple
and Amazon and Facebook and Google and
all these companies tend to be sort of
highly concentrated in these sort of
very I don't know so monolithic
corporate headquarters and our thesis is
that it's kind of several folds you know
partly that kind of the availability of
talent is becoming sort of far more
geographically dispersed partly that
sort of you know the Bay Area is going
an increasingly untenable expensive
location to locate and partly that sort
of we really want stripe to be global
infrastructure that work
kind of just as well in instead of you
know Asian markets or in Latin American
markets or whatever as it does for
businesses in the US and have the era of
the internet being asleep predominantly
North American or North America and
Western European or whatever the the
days of being kind of such a phenomenon
are over and so I think that's sort of a
fairly substantial break with kind of
you know descriptive best practice of
the past I mean you know we obviously
think it'll work and we wouldn't do it
if we didn't but it is also kind of them
on some level risky like we don't have
good you know prior examples to point to
and you know I mean there are some great
companies in Singapore like like grab
and carousel but aren't really any
examples yet a sort of American
companies establishing kind of major
private engineering hubs they're you
know we're pretty optimistic it can be
done but but you know kind of if it
works you know we'll be the first or one
of the first cool last question so in a
hundred years from now what is stripe
gonna be what do you imagine it to be
well we're only seven years old so
that's a difficult question to answer
we're trying to build this kind of this
economic infrastructure for the
International is sort of platform for
globalization and kind of technological
progress in the sense that like it ought
to be just as easy easy to start a
company in in in in sort of you know
Nigeria as it is in New York and it
should be just as easy for somebody in
Brazil to buy something so from any of
these companies as it is for for again
somebody in in the Western world and and
it just seems so crazy to me that sort
of that hasn't happened yet like I it
sort of feels that stripe should have
happened ten or twenty years before it
did and and just kind of I don't so much
think the were sort of pursuing this
kind of unprecedented kind of path
breaking I am sort of a inconceivable
idea so much as kind of correcting a
deficiency and instead of as a rip in
the fabric of Internet infrastructure
and and so anyway I think we still have
you know at least five years to go
instead of sort of correcting this
inadequacy yeah so what happens after
that I'm not sure in some sense in the
future all transactions should be
digital and they could very well it's
just the all going through strife I mean
right now like in the u.s. someone's
telling me like 80% of all Americans
have done some transaction Thursday
right yeah that's right so in the last
12 months more than 80 percent of
American adults have bought something
from a from a stripe business at least
one thing from a stripe business which
is cool and you know it's not just the
case in the u.s. like in Singapore I was
last week you know that that figure is
about 70 percent right but I guess we
don't think about it well I think about
it more in terms of the things that are
possible or get started as an its kind
of we think a lot about the rate of sort
of new firm creation what companies are
getting started how successful of those
companies which markets can they serve
and so on and you know every now and
again we look back and we look at sort
of the those kinds of market coverage
that's but I guess that's not really
about sort of them what motivates us is
it's more than sort of are these
businesses that should exist and or
should be able to kind of offer the
present services you know in these
places where they currently can't and
that's I think I mean that's the kind of
thinking that we use to kind of inform
the product and that's it is kind of the
the core on a locomotion day-to-day and
then maybe the outcome of that is is
that all these people get to benefit
from it all right thank you so much
Patrick this is great thank you
[Applause]
you